esto que tenemos aquí es una imagen de
un ejercicio en khan academy y dice
compara usando mayor que menor que o
igual que y a la izquierda tenemos un
cuarto por cinco mil y queremos
compararlo con cinco mil en can academy
haría clic en este menú desplegable y
elegiría mayor que menor que o igual que
entonces cuál crees que es la respuesta
correcta cómo se compara un cuarto de
cinco mil con cinco mil y como sabes que
tu respuesta es correcta elige una
respuesta pausa el vídeo y trata de
resolverlo bueno una forma de pensar en
esto es que si estoy multiplicando 5000
por algún valor ese valor va a escalar
5000 lo hará más pequeño o más grande o
en ciertos casos podría no cambiar el
tamaño en absoluto de hecho el caso en
el que 5000 no cambia es cuando lo
multiplicas por 11 por 5000 es igual a
5.000 pero qué crees que va a pasar
cuando multiplicas un valor entre 0 y 1
por 5000 eso será mayor que
qué o menor que 5000 bueno una forma de
imaginar lo es en una recta numérica
esto es 0 esto es 5 mil esto es la mitad
entre 0 y 5 mil y luego si divido este
espacio entre 0 y 5 mil en cuartos esto
sería un cuarto del camino entre 0 y 5
mil de modo que este valor que tenemos
aquí es un cuarto por 5000 bueno cómo se
compara este valor un cuarto por 5000
con 5000 está claro que un cuarto por
5000 es menor que 5000 y en general si
el valor que estás multiplicando por
otra cosa está entre 0 y 1 para que lo
que estás multiplicando sea más pequeño
si éste fuera uno el valor no cambiaría
y si éste fuera mayor que uno lo haría
más grande así que veamos estas opciones
porque estamos multiplicando 5000 por
una fracción que es menor que 1 sí eso
es exactamente lo que está pasando
estamos multiplicando 5000 por un cuarto
lo que nos dará un valor menor que 5000
esta opción veamos las otras opciones
porque estamos multiplicando 5000 por
una fracción que es igual a uno bueno no
un cuarto claramente no es igual a uno
así que descartamos esta porque estamos
multiplicando 5000 por una fracción que
es mayor que 1 bueno un cuarto
claramente no es mayor que 1 así que
también la descartamos hagamos otro
ejemplo
y nos preguntan el producto de cada
expresión es menor que igual que o mayor
que 49 pausa este vídeo y trata de
resolverlo muy bien primero tenemos 49
por siete octavos cuál crees que es
correcta
bueno siete octavos es menor que uno de
modo que se multiplicó 49 por algo menor
que 1 voy a obtener un valor menor que
49 así que me gusta esta opción que
tenemos aquí 49 por cinco medios bueno
cinco medios es mayor que uno recuerda
dos medios es igual a uno entonces cinco
medios es mayor que uno sí estoy
multiplicando 49 por un valor que es
mayor que 1 voy a obtener un valor mayor
que 49
y por último pero no menos importante
cuarenta y nueve por tres tercios bueno
tres tercios es exactamente igual a uno
entonces cuarenta y nueve por uno será
exactamente igual a 49 y hemos terminado